it is far more fun to die on your sword
than to die on someone else's dying on
your sword is better than dying on
someone else's so many of you are doing
things making decisions and navigating
your lives based on somebody else's
thesis you're doing it because you think
it's the right thing because your dad's
telling you it's the right thing you're
doing what you're doing right now
because you're pandering to your boss
even though you don't believe in it this
is how it's going to play out you are
doing things right now yesterday you
made a decision that you don't believe
in but you're smart you did it because
you know how your company scores here's
the problem with disruption and
innovation right now you're being
rewarded for being a yes person and in
36 months you're gonna be fired for
being a yes person and you're doing it
because you just need the security of
your job i'm telling you right now if
you're watching this vlog that means you
have a certain dna please i implore you
please die on your sword not somebody
else's if you're going to lose it's much
more fun to lose based on what you
thought do you know how many of you are
going to lose on somebody else's thesis
it's going to kill at you it's going to
eat at you it's going to be the worst
feeling so please pause this video right
now and ask yourself am i doing my
because of me then you're good whether
you're winning or losing or am i doing
it because somebody else is telling me
it's the right way or i'm subconsciously
pandering to please somebody or
something because i need the short-term
stability figure that the [ __ ] out you
know it and i know it you just need to
do something about it want to be happy
build a life not just a business hey
it's evan carmichael and this channel is
created to help you overcome the number
one challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's have your best believe
life and get some incredible motivation
from the one and only gary vaynerchuk
everybody wanted to be an astronaut one
day
like every kid that i'm looking at these
good looking kids they all wanted to be
astronauts and pilots in 1957.
what do they want to be now
entrepreneurs i mean this is my moment
and by the way
it'll be fun and in nine years the world
will melt everybody will not be an
entrepreneur anymore it won't be cool
they'll blame entrepreneurship for the
melt and i'll still be an entrepreneur
because that's what i've always been
that's what i am now and that's what
i'll be to the last breath if you're a
purebred entrepreneur you love the dark
clouds you understand that the fake
entrepreneurship hero we live through
loves the sunshine when it's good and
happy and easy but if it's in your dna
if you actually are an entrepreneur you
know exactly why the upcoming era of
dark clouds is going to be very
important because at the end of the day
this is a game based on merit and if you
don't know how to navigate those storms
you can't be an all-time entrepreneur
i love the dark clouds because they're
part of the process by the way this
whole notion of like you can do anything
and all this stuff let me just tell you
it's stupid hard
reality is most of you are just
averagely talented
right
like you're not going to over index on
anything too crazy here's the good news
this is not about how much money you
make or how talented you are this is
about being happy
everybody here regardless of how
talented they are in making money or art
or what have you has that they're super
into
you love teenage mutant ninja turtles
your whole life can be about
michelangelo
it could and here's what really fits
with me in this internet age you could
have a podcast around teenage mutant
ninja turtles you could buy teenage
mutant ninja turtle memorabilia on
craigslist and facebook and etsy and
then flip it on a different platform
because you're so knowledgeable because
that's the piece of eating
leonardo
that i'm just fascinated about what
happens when you go all in on your
passion you're committed to it and you
use the infrastructure of this
you living your life for 80 years as the
teenage ninja turtle expert is getting
funnier to me by the second
making 83k a year in ads on your podcast
the flip some miraculous reason somebody
paid you two thousand dollars to go to a
bush league comic-con thing
that person making 62 000 a year being
the tmt
expert versus them making 77 000 a year
being an admin in a company where they
hate their life nine to five that delta
is something i will go to the grave on
because it is what i want to articulate
to everybody the
the unbelievable level of practicality
to do [ __ ] around stuff you like and
here's the big part
how many people under 40
let me just start with this group
if you just really took what i'm talking
about became an expert at facebook and
instagram really understood
the fact that you could take a leap for
two years move back in home move in
together cut your expenses i don't give
a sh the fact that you can do that for
two or three years and if it doesn't
work out you can go back
to getting a job
that's nuts
that's
nuts
you've got to break out of that pattern
you've got to not listen to him and make
money
in however way you want
listen otherwise you're stuck
if you want to help your mom sometimes
the best way to help your mom is to get
out and then come back and get her out
i get it so honestly honestly and i
respect that listen to me life is long
you're in a spot right now but my mom
didn't have her mom or dad at 14.
life is long it sucks right now
if when you're 14 it feels like it's
your life forever it's not your life
forever bro
you understand
surround yourself with as much
positivity to get you through this
chapter
i have no
there's only two choices here
you stay under that roof and each for
four more years three more years two
more years or you bounce now plenty of
people bounce to 14. it's not common in
the uk but people do it
or you don't
life's about a very simple
you either option
it or don't if you're gonna
under that route you need to put your
earpods in and listen to positivity 24 7
to get into that you understand
when your surroundings are your insides
got to be positive
the fact that you're even here means
you're halfway home
[Music]
hit me up any time dm right
all right you listening listen listen
when it's around you you have to make it
positive in your head i know it feels
like it's
forever and it's going to take forever
when you're 14 four more years sounds
like forever but you have no choice you
either bounce
or you stay and if you stay which is
more likely which is fine you gotta put
positivity in your ears
do you understand
i promise you you have no other
alternatives otherwise you just dwell
and you go down a spiral that you don't
want to go down
you understand if you've got debt or
have to put a roof over your head or
somebody else then you work whatever job
is paying you that
but i'm asking you what are you doing
from 6 p.m to midnight
and if you have to go build slowly your
portfolio your
shopify store your instagram account
your youtube channel your content like
like
wouldn't you be pumped if i told you
for the next four years it's tough and
you don't watch as much netflix and
sports and hanging out but then you get
to live happy for the rest of your life
everybody
in theory would sign up for that the
reality is a lot of people don't want to
grind for four years like people don't
like pain it's why most people don't
have six packs
i mean that i mean that there's a lot of
people here who want to be in better
shape you just don't want to work out
you just don't want to eat well i was at
the top of the wine game and i left
because i won and i didn't want to do it
anymore it went into marketing where
everyone like the first article written
about me was like this guy had wine
twitter i think the article in the big
advertising magazine was twitter boy is
what they call me twitter boy thinks
he's going to come and win madison
avenue
they're not laughing anymore you know
and even this game now i can already
feel it i'm like oh man
three four five years from now this
thing's a wrap i'm gonna be the guy so
i'm gonna have to start selling oranges
or something you know i gotta figure you
know i'm gonna have to figure something
out because i lose like i'm about to
climb back to sports i grew up with die
hard yankees jets rangers knicks fan
the yankees and rangers won their
championships i literally stopped
watching them
nicks and jets are gonna take me a
minute you know but like but like i'm
just about to i just love the climb like
even like back to sports because i think
it's great analogy i'll turn on a random
game i need to know who the underdog is
that's my team i'm just about to climb
you know like to me when i see a kid
wearing a steph curry jersey and that
kid lives in new york i think that gets
soft
i i mean it he's he's using somebody
else's success to make himself feel good
i think the biggest tell of a losing
person is wearing a jersey outside your
own city i think when i get the praise
it's what the [ __ ] does that have to do
with me
when i get [ __ ] on i'm like that's on me
and i'll fix it and i think those you
know that was a i said it really quick
but it's an accountability
it's accountability
and ownership when you suck
and it's
passing on the credit
when you
fuel
and that's it
and that's me and that's my makeup and
that's why i'm winning in life and
that's why i'm always going to win
because when you're
100 accountable
and you know you're
you're garbage when you're 100
accountable when there's an issue
and when you pass on the praise when
you're getting it
you become fundamentally undefeated
unbeatable i'm straight up unbeatable
because my head will never get gassed up
enough
ever when i'm getting it good
and uh
and i'll never believe it's me and when
it's bad i'll never point the pit finger
to anybody else all your finger pointers
pointing everywhere everybody's pointing
fingers pointing them everywhere it's
everybody's
yourself your country your environment
your parents school system your boss
and your
circumstances of course and of course
there's tragedies
and crimes and
child abuse and real bad stuff i'm not
saying it's not real i'm saying for the
95 of you
it's a mighty set thing perspective
perspective is everything
grounded in my perspective
never too high never too low
it's about them when it's good it's
about me when it's bad that's me
that's what i got for you that's where
i'm at that's my mindset
and i never waver
it's a hundred percent
never waiver i had my bad days
but
uh all bent out of shape he just said uh
today's rough to be very frank with you
vaynernation i don't give a [ __ ] if
tyler or you think today was rough
because i had 17 meetings that he
couldn't be a part of because i'm
actually running a business here i'm not
from some teenage beanie bopper trying
to do a vlog or something
influencer doing a blog or some family
that's hoping for some free detergent
because of their blog i'm
working here tyler so sorry that your
video blog is rough
but let me tell you what's not rough
what's not rough is we're living through
the great era of ground shift in
marketing and business
everybody in this amazing town of new
york city which is let me just tell you
everybody who's not here
vibrant at 10 00 p.m right now because
98 of your cities are sleeping
everybody here is their collective pants
because the ground is shifting
everything that our grandparents and
parents grew up with everything that we
knew tried and true the stable
pillars of media commerce
uh influence
persuasion the way we make decisions the
things we buy and how what is cool and
what is not is on
call
the world is on call
and you know what that means hustlers
the opportunity is obnoxious so whether
you're focusing on vlogs
or influencers
or how to hack instagram stories
or how to create alexa voice skills
or how to create your own podcast
because you see i'm
full committed till if you are not
following my podcast
pissed
the way i call today the the sum up of
all my meetings today none of which you
just watched
is that the earth is moving
there's instability in the foundation of
how it was which makes an innovator like
me really happy and what suffocates all
you b players because you like it you
like it nice slow and stable let me be
very clear with this ending rant that
game is over and the people that are
going to win over the next five to seven
years are gonna be very comfortable in
controlled
chaos so you better get your speed up
you better work harder you better work
smarter you better try things you better
keep your subjectiveness and your ego at
the door because that slows you down and
it doesn't make you do you better
move people always like i can't get my
cashiers to like
work because they're only 12 bucks an
hour i'm like no it's because you've
never said hello to them face
right so like i'm very people centric i
think there's enormous roi either in the
short term or the long term
some of the people that work for me iris
may go on to win an academy award as a
filmmaker right like i'd much rather
have her like me than not like me
you know everybody's playing short term
i don't live as if tomorrow i'm gonna
die and i'm stunned by how many people
do it's all short-term roi
every decision is short-term roi and i
think that's a huge decision so
internally i spend a lot of time and
money my hr department too big
my time that i spend with employees too
much this is what i hear from all my
business associates who then spend all
their time asking me how i do it your
employees for me it's my employees first
then the customer then i can even begin
to think about what the [ __ ] in it for
me
and i've just watched 95 of the business
i interact with start with them
then the customer then their employees
i think that most of the people are
broken and i think if you have if you
are if you're honest no [ __ ] right
if it just went through your mind like i
am me then customer than my employees
you will lose
[Music]
and i can tell you that's the majority
of businesses i am stunned by how many
people here don't realize that the
quickest path
to happiness or
more economics in business given the
context of this talk
happens to be in the thing that they
love the most yet they're not willing to
each for the next three to five years to
get there let me explain
it blows me away
that if you're ridiculously passionate
about the teenage mutant ninja turtles
now stick with me i know this is going
weird
that starting your instagram account
your podcast and your youtube channel
about leonardo and michelangelo
and putting out that content
for a three year period
in the long tail of the internet in the
way that niche marketing works if you
focus on that seven pm to two in the
morning around that world that literally
within three to four years the
practicality
if you're consistent
to making between fifty and a hundred
thousand dollars a year in affiliate
ebay links and sponsorship around being
the foremost expert
of teenage mutant ninja turtles
is a very fascinating thing how many
people
here and across this country right now
rushed to buy cryptocurrency
[Music]
because that's where the gold rush was
i'm just fascinated by people's passion
for the quick fix
versus the marathon
i'm fascinated by people willing to put
in their body to lose 15 pounds that's
some private label horse from china
versus
eating right and exercising let me
promise you something good
and that's how i want to say it
everything special
is
hard i think the biggest vulnerability
you've got
is you actually value somebody's opinion
more than you value your own
like the reason i've been able to always
do my thing
is when i was 24 and people were like oh
you work at your dad's liquor store
like
i heard that as like a chip on my
shoulder
you know i loved it i was like cool keep
sleeping on me
you know
like i'm glad you're on wall street
making a hundred thousand buying bmws
and dumb jewelry i'll see you in 30
years you understand
like to me the way you win
is you realize you can't hear nobody not
your parents i mean listen you got to
listen to coach and all that i get it
but at the end of the day my guy
yourself you got to get real real quiet
up here i can't hear anything you go
look at my instagram right now my first
post i'll post something first 100
replies in one second you're jesus you
walk on water you're the best you're the
all-time can't hear them the next
hundred you're a piece of [ __ ] you're
full of you're a snake oil salesman
can't hear him
i'm in my own mind doing my own thing
and that comes with self-esteem
everybody's trying to keep up with the
joneses
i'm not worried about you being on the
in the hamptons on a blow up swan
i'm not worried about you
renting out cash from the bank and
putting it to your ear
i'm not worried you jumped the fence and
took a photo in front of a private plane
what do you think these people are doing
they're posing
patience long game you know what's
amazing about being an entrepreneur we
get to play forever i'm going to be
working when i'm 96
trying to find my next hustle first
thing that you need to think about is
you start need to think about yourself
as espn and hbo and cnbc and the new
york times the quicker all of you think
of yourself as that
everything changes i literally think
that i gary vee
don't compete with richard branson or
with you know mark cuban i think that
garyvee competes with
business insider and forbes
and and you know the wall street journal
and complex magazine like i i don't
think about competing with humans i
spend zero time even debating that
and so i think of myself carlos as a
media company
and so it's the difference between you
know what i think a lot of people do in
our world
they turn into infomercials
versus 2020.
if you make content on facebook and
linkedin and your email and everything
you do if you think of yourself as
abc news
if you think about yourself as fox or
cnn
instead of an infomercial
changes everybody's thinking like an
advertiser not as a media company
and i think for a lot of you it seems
like you know i'm watching your kind of
behavior that's why i feel a little bit
different
i'm not putting out content like an
advertiser with a short-term goal
i'm putting out content like a media
company with a long-term goal
which creates short-term opportunity
[Music]
it's a very very subtle but
disproportionate reason and and the
luckier you are if you're this legendary
as people are whispering to me
well then that means you're sitting with
something which means
you should be recording all of it
all of it
that's right and the way to think about
it is some of you don't have the dollars
to hire somebody yet and neither did i
for the first eight years the whole
drock thing and all this this you know i
love when everyone's like easy for you
gary you have drock now and i'm like i
didn't have anybody
for eight years
and i built up to it and then i had
somebody
so like if you've got to do it in selfie
form good and if like for me i can't
write i have a ghostwriter for my books
i have a ghostwriter for my linkedin a
medium right now i can't write it's not
how i communicate
but i can do video some of you
are scared of video and get awkward
you're more introverted so then write
use the medium that helps you best
communicate and then build around it
most people here
will be successful
if they could be more patient for longer
yet
most people will fail in here if they're
delusional and keep doing the same thing
for a long time waiting for the thing to
happen it's one and the same
the most difficult question for me to
answer is when should you stop doing
what you're doing
because i actually have to spend time
with you
and really look under the hood to know
are you completely in outer space and
have a terrible idea and you stink and
of course we should change it
or
the other thing that so many people
struggle with you're so impatient
and you're so caught up in short-term
metrics like how many followers you have
or how many sales you made or how many
leads did you generate that you quit too
soon because nothing happens overnight
it's one and the same dudes that were
trying to kill it didn't use words like
empathy and gratitude seven years ago
like seeing like sleeved up like rad
dudes roll up to me like yo kindness dog
i'm like
it's just so and honestly i genuinely
believe my great legacy potentially
may be that i made emotionally
intelligent
soft skills alpha you know you'll never
believe this this is super interesting
to me
the fact that pink was a boy's color
and blue was a girl's color back in the
day
is kind of how i think about gratitude
empathy kindness i'm like i'm going to
trick these young dogs
into like thinking this is cool and then
one day in 50 years people can be like
the alpha male traits are like gratitude
and kindness and if i could pull that
off then it's like
i don't think there's anything wrong
with chasing money
i just think that it's usually the
quickest way not to get it
i really believe that
i really do i think when i watch people
that are driven by money
i see a lot of unhappiness and failure
it's very common if we did the happy
meter here it's the people that are i
promise you it's the people that are
doing what they want to be doing like to
me i couldn't explain to you enough and
i have um unmost empathy for the
cynicism around this statement
it's unbelievable how much i don't like
money
i like the game
i love my game i love the game of
building
i wake up at six o'clock in the morning
and go garage sailing
because there's nothing like pulling up
literally to this day i can't replicate
the high of going to a garage sale
walking into a yard of junk
and finding something for a dollar that
i know i can sell on ebay for 17 bucks
is a bigger happiness high
than closing a 6 million account for
vayner and it's not even close
that's what i want for everybody because
that's how they get the 20. opportunity
needs preparation that's something a lot
of people talk about i'll tell you what
i believe in i believe that there's so
much opportunity at all times that it's
actually preparation
everybody's prepared finds their
opportunity
yeah so so
sure i believe in it but here's what i
actually believe in
opportunity is abundant
we live in a world that has unlimited
opportunity especially if you're willing
to look for it
looking for it is predicated on the fact
that you put in the work
you put in the work
because you knew that you were going to
go look for it so
i believe in preparation preparation
preparation
because i just believe that opportunity
is almost like oxygen it's everywhere
always and some opportunities are bigger
than others
but preparation man people don't do
people convince themselves before they
start that the world is unjust or they
can't or things are [ __ ] up they
complain they dwell they say no before
they say yes and of course look if you
say no
it's already over like literally if you
wake up and say it's not gonna happen
for me
it's already over you you might as well
not try my friends this is a remarkably
special time and i'm completely
convinced the far majority and i mean 99
of this room is going to regret it i'm
completely convinced about it it's not
fun for me to say that but it's very
obvious to me that humans take for
granted and are really bad at
perspective and timing the reason i push
patience how many people here are under
30. raise your hands
stand up if you're under 30 don't be a
stand up
let's first of all clap it up for all
the youngsters in the room
keep standing you're young you're not
tired yet
if you're standing right now you really
have to like let's get into perspective
and actual understanding if you're
standing right now with the way that
modern medicine is actually evolving
there is a very high percentage
that you're gonna live
three more lives that you've already
lived if not five
like do you understand why i struggle
when people give up on
a year or two in or are upset that they
haven't gotten there yet three years in
when you faces are about to live four
more lives
i'm being serious like you're literally
gonna live four more lives five more
like from the day you were born that you
cannot remember
to write this second you're about to do
that three to four more times
you can sit literally
literally
your biggest advantage is timing for all
the great
things that i have in my life i would
literally give it up all of it all of it
just to be 25 i would give up for 17
years i'd give up everything i have
because that's how valuable time is
and the far majority of this room has
time
time as their asset
and every day the number one asset they
have time they give away by being
impatient mainly on the back of
listening to society or their parents
that they have to have their figured out
at this age the fact that people
actually think at 18
22 or 30 you have to have your figured
out is ridiculous let me promise you all
those parents and uncles and
grandparents that push down your throat
that you have to figure it out by now
they still haven't figured it the [ __ ]
out
i mean it
so this
nonsense this
nonsense that you have to have it
figured out at 18 22 30. you know how
many people freaked the [ __ ] out at 30.
how many people are 30 right now
that was crazy right
like people lose their at 30.
like meanwhile they're a
kid
and so i'm unbelievably
um aware lately that one of the you know
people are always like why do you when i
talk about my parents and not coming
from anything but the more that i live
i'm like the reason i really win
is because i understand time
and listen i know i can get hit by a bus
or get terminally ill i get it here's
the problem that's far more unlikely for
the majority of us the math works in
your favor and we are stunningly not
patient
patience has been the foundation of my
patience adversity these are the
foundations of my success the reason i
love hard work is it's controllable it's
hard for me to be like be more talented
[Music]
you know that seems like like when
people like you push hard you know a lot
of
politically correct you know over
extreme european points of view get mad
at me gary you're it's unhealthy you
can't gary v you can't go to the grave
with all your money i'm like dude i'm
not talking about money
and i don't feel like it's work when i
love it like maybe you don't like your
job as much asking for a one percent of
one percent life
so far i've heard i didn't want to eat
and put out stuff and deal with no
feedback for a year or two i don't want
to spend the three or four hours to like
learn it because it seems like there's
so much you have to realize when you're
asking to do to live a one percent life
that you need to do one percent things
dude i worked in a liquor store for 15
hours a day seven days a week for years
and somehow people put that as like part
of my narrative but don't give it the
respect the word that drives my life is
actually context not content i talk so
much about content the reason i
am successful at what i do and my
companies are successful and the
companies i advise are successful and
the people that follow are successful is
because they're great at context not
just content
clearly if you don't have context on the
other person if you're not deploying
empathy for the other person if you're
not
worried about them then you have no shot
it's really no different than giving a
speech
the reason i'm a dominant public speaker
and one of the best at what i do
is because i'm far more worried in the
next 32 minutes plus about delivering
you value and giving stuff for you not
what i can get out of it for me you know
some speakers get confused and they want
your money i don't want your money i
want you to win and then send me an
email that you won the other thing i'm a
very big believer in is getting people
to not feel like it's a scarlet letter
if they lose
something nobody talks about at all is
your scenario you jump
it fails
you reset and go back
and get a job in the craft that you had
because of your resume
and you restart in four years from now
we have we so
america's pretty good at looking at
losses in a positive way compared to
other parts of the world where it's like
a true scarlet letter death forever
but still even here
you know people don't know when to go
back
from their jump
because they don't want the loss on the
resume
they made the big to-do that they're
gonna you're gonna do it
now it doesn't work and what they do is
they triple down into debt
to look good in front of people and what
if it did and you never jumped to find
out oh you're preaching that i want
you've already done that i'm actually
talking about the next part which is
having the options
to know that the game is super long and
that if the business when you go from
ice cold when you go from never having a
business to having a business that's
like literally asking me i'm asking you
to right now qualify for wimbledon in
tennis
it's a lot harder than people think
you're grown you two are grown
i'm not trying to suppress by the way
i'm talking about the practicality of
like options
i love that we live in a world i'm
trying to get people to like really
understand how to win this
so much of my success is completely
predicated on not worrying about all my
losses which means at times you know my
great losses are the things i passed on
maybe i should have done shark tank
maybe maybe
maybe not
i don't think i should have done it
not this late in i think i'll do my own
thing like you know like but i could but
i mean there's a lot of i mean i didn't
invest in uber
when i could have made 400 million
i mean that's a loss tip of the day stop
listening to anybody but yourself
outside noises
so many of them
imagine athletes stopping
every time
they heard people booing them or talking
while they were on the court that's how
i think about being an entrepreneur
like of course or or just living life
like just imagine that like you're on
the free line and somebody like just
they cry or they don't take the shot
nobody is going to cry for you they have
their own tears
one thing
one thing i'm positive about is how roi
negative complaining is
and how much i'm trying to suffocate the
practice of it
i really have been fascinated by people
that
have changed their mindset into
understanding that everything that is
not going well right now is their fault
it has been remarkably
important to me
in understanding that everything that
i'm not happy about has is on me
it's it's a remarkably interesting brain
twist the amount of energy spent on
things that you can't control
versus being accountable to what you can
control has been a huge separator for me
in the last four or five years as i've
dug deep no question
the quickest way to happiness is
accountability when people start looking
for somebody else to be at fault
whether it's the government or their
aunt or some or their boss they always
lose everybody's putting out the best
photo from their vacation ever
everybody's putting out the most
exciting night of their lives people are
actually now doing things in real life
just for the photo to put on instagram
and this is very important to understand
because we as humans are wired
often to envy
and be jealous and curious and dwell on
not being on that boat and what that
leads to is short-term behavior
everybody's looking to make a quick
dollar
so that they can go on that yacht or go
to a visa or buy that car or that bag or
that sneaker and this is 100 the poison
that is in the system
and so for me i want to know why
why do you want to be successful
for me i didn't even really necessarily
want to be successful i just couldn't
breathe if i wasn't selling something or
building a business it's all i knew
there was nothing else it was why i was
such a bad student i couldn't even
appease the hour i needed to be a decent
student a day because i needed every
minute
selling baseball cards or wine or
whatever i was up to at that point in my
life there was no choice
and so that's what i wish on everybody
else i wish that you wake up every
morning and have no choice
that what you do is how you breathe
let's say you opened a bar a barber shop
you want to sell t-shirts like the one
big advantage you guys have look i have
a huge company my company's gonna do 200
million dollars in revenue i just flew
from craft we have budweiser we have the
biggest brands in the world chase
they still don't get it
i'm sitting in meetings every day and
they're not pouring enough money into
social media that's your advantage
they're still pouring it into
commercials and print and things of that
nature so
you know where the attention is
and so social matters but humans and
relationships are just honestly my man i
said it like i can't explain to you
enough how much i want you to meet every
person look some of you are introverts
if you're an extrovert and you're social
you need to go all in
on the fact that you got blessed with
that dna that you love people and you
love saying hello and you've got the
leverage of doing what you're doing now
some of you are introverts right and
that's hard but like i'm gonna keep
pushing too because the leverage just
absurd i do think people are capable of
dramatically more than they expect
but you know
there's you know listen i could be a
dramatically bet bigger and better
singer than i am right now which isn't
zero
but there's also a very fine line of
extending yourself and then bleeding
into delusion
there is no scenario where i'm gonna be
frank sinatra or beyonce and so
i think one of the things that i worry
about especially in my field of
entrepreneurship do i think that most
people
can
replicate their salary
at a job that they hate
by starting an online business
and over a seven year period make the
same amount of money
talking about or producing content or
selling things around skiing or jam
making or shoes than they did as being a
miserable clerk at a retail store yes i
do do i think most people are capable
of making a million dollars a year
running a business no i do not and i
think that's in a very
it's a where i think these debates
become too black and white
and some people are like oh it's just
about mindset and positivity and you can
do it and everybody's a hater and a
troll or the reverse where people are
like all these people are full of
they're selling them [ __ ] and snake
oil
the reason that is and the reason i
wrote crush it if you ever really really
read it
i believe in passion and optimism
and pushing yourself but i
disproportionately believe in
practicality patience and hard work too
the number one thing practical that you
can get out of this talk go home and
start doing is realize that if you're
not communicating to the world
then you're in trouble
because attention is the asset and
whether you're producing content or
you're running advertising if you're not
doing one of those two things you're
actually really vulnerable my biggest
concern is there's a lot of people here
who are actually having a good year how
many people here are having their best
year in their business raise your hands
that's phenomenal excites the [ __ ] out
of me it also scares me to no end
because if you're winning without the
stuff that i believe in it means that
you're vulnerable the reason you're
seeing videos of me pop up talking about
toys r us or sears or other thing in
trouble and now it makes me look really
smart is because seven or eight years
ago
they weren't doing the things that i
knew they had to do to be successful
today that became their vulnerability if
you're selling a ton of homes or you're
getting more clients than ever or you're
whatever it is whatever success you're
having if you're doing that without
producing a high volume of content every
day on facebook twitter linkedin
instagram you know youtube or a podcast
you're immediately right this second
vulnerable
because somebody else is going to and
over time they will take your audience
they will
and so i highly recommend that the
tangible thing that you do from this
talk is that you realize that you have
to go home and figure out how you're
going to communicate to the world
happiness is so important i'm so
obsessed with it right now and i hate
that success and entrepreneurship and
all this stuff have been put on a
pedestal do you understand that most
people think they need to make a million
dollars a year to be like winning
meanwhile in america one of the richest
countries in the world 440 000
is the entry into the one percent
we have we have success
completely completely misunderstood
we have success
completely misunderstood let me tell you
what success looks like when you wake up
in the morning and you're happy i talk
about hustle here's why if i looked at
all of us right now and everybody behind
these cameras or reading this article
and said
get smarter
more talented i want you to get more
talented
that's very tricky
that's unbelievably ideological advice
if i said look two extra hours of work
actually has an impact on your success
if that's what you're trying to achieve
that's practical yeah you don't have to
but it's controllable work ethic is
controllable
being born with talent is not the way i
do branding
i sell so infrequently
that i think some of you that are
watching me the hardest core
need to hear this which is it's okay to
sell especially if you believe in
something like if you believe in what
you're selling and that's what i'm
spending a lot of time on now trying to
spend more time
on really getting to a place where i
really believe in stuff instead i was
just passive not creating so i wasn't
selling because i didn't believe you
know and just letting everything come to
me
but as i create these you know events
vayner experience a lot of events very
big on events events are so valuable
just watching the 4ds crew it's value
and like how it's impacting their
business for ten thousand dollars right
there i mean you see i know you're
getting emails
um
the wine club like 150 worth of wine for
55 bucks like i've just locked into
members it's going to make all your
thanksgivings ridiculous
the conference 500
2 hour session in my stomping grounds
good deal compared to like other
conferences that i speak at
um
but you're getting the wine for free or
you're getting the talk for free and
you're getting the wine so like
i'm very fascinated because i'm putting
more pressure on myself to create things
that i really believe in
which then allows me to sell more and i
just think for a lot of you
selling the ask the right hook is very
difficult uh you're you're passive you
like the idea of like feeling good about
like giving out content this and that
when you believe in something
you can sell it and and you should put
more pressure on yourself to create
things that you believe in biggest
problem is so many of you sell you don't
believe in you're just doing it for the
money you're gonna lose
that i don't like i know that if i can
suffocate all of you today to take 25
of your take-home income this year and
pour it back into two people who do
video and written word
and put it into facebook and instagram
ads literally all of you will email me
24 months actually
if you can start right away literally
25 of you are going to come to me this
time next year right here and be like
holy sh
i've been listening to your stuff for
seven years
your keynote was different in miami last
year at this time i listened i said
i don't need to go to ibiza three times
this year
i don't need to buy a better bmw this
year to make me feel good with the
neighbors
i don't need another pair of supremes or
yeezys i took the money and i put it
into karen the film
woman and rick the ad guy
and now my business is 2x this will 100
work
even if you suck
on camera
have zero charisma
are only eight days in the industry this
will work
because it is such
underpriced attention that the roi will
work that if you're
a two
in skill
the ads are a 20 in the 10 point scale
and it closes the delta of you being
average if you literally literally and
i've said this for seven years if you
literally literally go interview the guy
who owns the gym in town the guy who
owns the pizza shop the woman that owns
the insurance brokerage if you literally
literally
literally just interview your local
community that you become the local
newspaper
in three minute video form on your phone
you don't even need to hire drock or
babin or eyes your
phone if you literally take it selfie it
and interview the principal of the
school in your neighborhood
you will become the local celebrity
who can then transact on whatever you're
trying to sell that group if you bring
value to people if you interview the
best high school basketball player
literally just that
your business will change or
if you literally just give the advice of
how you got here
what you learned if you shared your
thoughts
if you do not understand that you were a
media company
then you will not be as successful as
you are today in a decade
and that's not interesting when the
alternative is you're four to seven
times bigger the state guys you have to
understand what happened to blockbuster
and netflix what happened with uber and
taxi companies what happened with hotels
versus airbnb
is happening with you as a human in your
business
and so when you have the best hand and
you know it because you've been paying
attention and you know how to play poker
you go all in
everybody here is playing facebook
instagram social media youtube
podcasting like they have the best hand
and they're calling
and you're not goading them into getting
all the money you're just folding
and that's this audience so can you
imagine what i feel is going on outside
this stadium
so this is a call to action for
everybody
to do me one favor and i do think i can
get a lot of you to do it which excites
the [ __ ] out of me
please
right now listen maybe you've laid out
money maybe you're in the middle of a
renovation maybe you're paying for your
kids college mazel tov i know there's
nuances on everybody's life but if you
were in a position where literally your
take-home income this year is literally
the stuff you're going to go and do
things with
please
from 25 percent to 90 percent if you can
go humble
please take that money and hire two
people to make a lot more content for
you about you and your business
and please give the rest of the money to
facebook
and youtube
and instagram
and i fundamentally promise you you will
walk here to this conference next year
and personally thank me emotionally
because your business will change and i
know not one of you has gone all in two
are trying to all things our social
media presence here
and wherever you are
so do get out your phone and follow joe
hyde
on instagram and like the
facebook page for prn
did you really think that was a good
idea
no bro i honestly think that that was
one of like the worst moves i've ever
seen because
[Applause]
and i and i'm not trying to razz you i
appreciate i'm trying to give you love i
love the passion to win the problem is
you tried to close on the first move
you brought them no value and you asked
them to bring you value
like you gave like i will stand up here
and give a load of value and never
mention one time for any of them to
follow me and a lot more of them will
follow me than they're going to follow
that [ __ ] move that you just did
i get it i get it but this was back to
the question that just happened that's
why i want you to win that move is
always gonna lose you can't go tonight
when you go out in vegas and you see a
pretty girl at the bar you can't go up
to her and the opening move is like
here's my key let's go
but that's what you just did let them
hold it but that's what you just did to
this audience with business because this
is an industry where it's kind of like
doggy dog world so
why why are you succeeding
and getting all your secrets away at the
same time
i mean because doing the right thing is
the right thing
karma is practical
[Applause]
you know
i heard somebody rant earlier right i
was like hey when i win i don't think
it's coming out of you the guy that
closed i couldn't know who was on stage
but i believe in that right because i
love the idea of 85 people here going
and listening to me winning i didn't
make anything for it but it then becomes
brand if she goes out and listens and
then two years later she's having dinner
with a friend and she's talking about
what happened to her life that friend
might be the ceo of ge you know i'm
playing with the biggest brands in the
world i'm not trying to monetize my
audience i'm trying to like just bring
the most value in the world and let that
lift all my other opportunities so i
think i think giving away your best
secrets is the greatest strategy for two
reasons karma is practical and leads to
more business but here's the secret and
it's even funnier
99 of these people are not going to do
anything about it
somewhere about five or six years ago i
realized this fact
holy sh
people aren't going to do anything with
this
so
like there's still going to be plenty
for me and i'm going to be the most
lovable guy ever i love this so
you know i was born in belarus in the
former soviet union
i came to the u.s when i was three we
lived a very humble beginning as you can
imagine the economy wasn't super great
we didn't speak english we had 100 bucks
i lived with seven family members in a
studio apartment in queens
so it was super humble as you and
you know obviously my parents are very
much my heroes uh one because my mom is
the greatest parent of all time and two
because my dad worked his face off and
even though
i slept under the same roof literally
every day of my life with my dad in the
first 14 years of my life i literally
never saw him because he left at 7am or
6am and he came home at 10pm and he
worked 7 days a week
how many people here are immigrants or
children of immigrants raise your hands
awesome so
this group that just raised their hands
they know that immigrants in america
have absolutely figured out one of the
core secrets which is
you know work your face off and don't
buy dumb
and so
that's kind of what my family did for
seven or eight years you know we my dad
wasn't making that much money but a
funny thing happens when you buy nothing
but food at the lowest possible price
and save save save save and very quickly
only six years after coming to america
with 100 bucks my dad was able to buy a
small liquor store in new jersey we
moved to new jersey that is where my
entrepreneurial career began
when i was six
i had a
five lemonade stand franchise
i
manipulated my friends into standing
behind the lemonade all day and that is
when i became obsessed with attention
and this is really interesting as you
can see up here i day trade attention
culture and build businesses
at six years old
i would spend my summer days literally
walking up and down the streets of new
jersey sitting down on the curb watching
cars drive by so that i could figure out
which tree or post was better for me to
put a sign that said lemonade a quarter
that is dna that's like somebody singing
that's like somebody throwing a pitch
really like that is just pure dna i
didn't read a seth godin book or go to
harvard business school to figure out
that attention was the number one asset
the one thing that combines every person
here from the cameramen back there who
are producing to the industry that is in
this room to me to mickey to anybody
else that sneaked in the one thing that
fundamentally connects all of us is
before you tell me how great your
product and services you need my
attention so that i listen i am obsessed
with attention i am obsessed with this
device because it has the attention i am
unemotional if it's ruining the kids and
they don't know how to engage or that
you were sad that people go out to
dinner and don't talk to each other
technology does not care about your
feelings
and so i as a human may have some
opinions about parenthood and society
and privacy as a human but as a
businessman i am unemotional and not
romantic all i do is follow where the
attention is and i figure out how to
storytell in there to create the action
that i desire how much time do you spend
on marketing
you said those four things how much time
do you actually spend on it
in a day zero sometimes i assume
in a week how much do you spend it
two hours great now is the most
important part of this meeting
how many hours do you sleep at night
great so i love the way you said it i
have to have seven so if i wanted to say
go to six so that you pick up five
you're gonna say to me gary i have to
have seven right
now let's go somewhere else i have to
know what you're doing the other 17
hours
i would bet the house
that we can find an hour every day
i guarantee it because you might be
working all 17 hours but you might not
be working on something smarter than
spending an hour a day on the thing that
you're talking about
do you understand yeah that's i mean
look that's the answer
the answer is time
you know people talk about working hard
and working smart the answer is only
both
you have to work hard and smart based on
your ambition
if you want to build a business for
yourself
that is like a one percent life
most people don't understand what
building a business for yourself is it's
very special
it's very special trying to build a
business for yourself everybody's doing
now
pulling it
off trying to play basketball everybody
can try
being an nba player
trying to be a rapper
or a singer
everybody's doing pulling it off
trying to be a footballer an actress
got it
so you're trying great pulling it off is
hard it takes everything
time and smarts
you need seven i'm glad you said it that
way because this makes this piece of
content more valuable
it's the 17 other hours
i'll give you an example a lot of people
drive to work for 45 minutes if they
took a bus for an hour and 15 minutes
they would save money and get more work
done
but do you have the humility to take the
bus versus driving your car how many
hands
work somewhere but want to do their own
thing raise your hands
more than half this audience
meanwhile
let me tell you why most of the hands
that just went up will never get there
they buy dumb
do you know how many people here
literally drive cars to impress people
that they
hate
people literally going in debt or
getting further from leaving the job
they don't like to do something that'll
make them happy because they have to buy
a certain car that has a logo that
impresses people that they despise
do you understand how
up that is
do you know how many people here live in
homes where they don't use more than
half the rooms in the house
like we are so fundamentally in a vortex
that makes no sense
that i am unbelievably passionate
understanding how much money you make
and what you can do to get off of it but
the problem is again people are doing so
many things to keep up with the joneses
to make it look like they're successful
to appease their parents and a million
other things that have nothing to do
with themselves
and we need to change that game in 1996
my dad had a liquor store in new jersey
that's as traditional as you get yeah
that was 22 years ago
and
and i put my dad's store on online and i
did email marketing and i did google and
i did content and then a couple months
after youtube came out i started a
youtube show in 2006 which is now 12
years ago
i
i i have no respect
or
normally i deploy a lot of empathy i i
struggle deploying empathy i struggle
deploying compassion if you were a
business operator
in 2018
heading in but i'm recording this in
october 2019 which is the majority of
people are going to listen to this and
you and your excuses while i'm a pub or
i make tomato juice or i have three
restaurants
like i digital is oxygen
it's it's it's the real world
feels secondary yeah like to not be a
communicator content producer
um part of the conversation like it's
it's now it's gone from cute and naive
to grossly negligent yeah
and
i just think it's unacceptable
to be a business in 2019 in the same way
that it would be to pay people not
minimum wage like i literally believe
it's grossly unacceptable like to me
it's like it's like to quantify digital
versus traditional just marketing like
really you think sending direct mail
print
is a better thing to do than advertising
on instagram as a restaurant like like
really like really sit down with me
you're telling me right now that it's a
better deal to spend all that money
making a flyer and sending it direct
mail
or running a radio ad
or buying a small little ad in a
newspaper like this is what you're
telling me it is 2019. i felt bad in
2002. it was early the internet was new
i had compassion it was cute in 2007 it
was like
it was kind of like
like hey
annoying kind of like
but still kind of in 2012 is like you're
not smart in 2019 like
you deserve to die everybody thinks i'm
so lucky and i'm like you're lucky you
went to high school parties yeah i
worked i went home 75 of my weekends
during my college career taking amtrak
not even maxella no first class
amtrak eating a [ __ ] sandwich which
i kind of loved and i missed that
sandwich
get get into new york not new york not
even new york which would be fun
woodbridge new jersey train station at
like 8 o'clock my dad would pick me up
we'd drive home and then i would wake up
at 6 30 in the morning and work in the
liquor store on saturday and then leave
back to boston on sunday and now i'm
lucky
it's hard to it's hard to think you're
lucky when you eat when nobody else is
eating we put out a shoe with k-swiss it
was our third one with them called uh
clouds and dirt which is basically my
thesis in life which is
macro micro have ambitions but you have
to you have to put in work to do that
right like you know everything matters
nothing matters just i'm a very
i'm a contradiction and within that
contradiction and a lot of people hit me
up they're like you're a stoic i'm like
what is that i googled them like oh
maybe maybe i am like i was like what
what i know i am is happy
and i'm happy because i keep things in
perspective and keeping things in
perspective i just tweeted something
uh that said there's a very fine line
between perseverance and delusion and
it's this question people always ask me
like when should i give up gary i've
been doing this you know rapping thing
i've been doing this vlog i've been
doing this restaurant it's not going
well two and a half years in and i can
never answer it because you need to know
the nuances and the details sure but
there is an incredible inflection point
in everybody's life speaking about your
early childhood like acting the amount
of people that literally were like one
more audition
this isn't working for me one more
audition and that's the one right or one
more song one more album one more
startup one more day at their job
there's a one more try to ask this boy
out right there's all these things of
like
when is it too much and you just waste
your life and you go into depression or
when was it perfect contradictions i'm
fascinated by them
but i'm always on the optimistic side of
them
mainly because when it doesn't work out
my big thing is
well you now know it doesn't work you
now know you aren't a rapper and good
news you're 31 you have your whole life
in front of you do you understand how
crazy it is that if you went to the
clearance aisles of your five biggest
retailers in australia bought things on
clearance went home relisted it and
posted on ebay that the far majority of
this audience could make between 50 to
100 000
a year
just on doing that for nine to ten hours
a day
meanwhile everybody's sitting here with
the next big app that's going to be the
next
uber for lawn mowers
the thing that has made me successful
far more than my passion or my energy is
my disproportionate practicality
most people want to look the part of an
entrepreneur that came up with the next
supreme or adidas brand or the next uber
or facebook
yet are forty thousand dollars in debt
work in a job that they hate and
literally
if they went to the five discount stores
that dominate this market buy things on
clearance go home take a picture with
their phone and upload to ebay and then
when people buy it go to the post office
and ship it
they would be able to get out of debt
and get into a financial place but
people don't want to do that
because they don't want to be judged for
that being their hustle
most people in this room in this world
would rather lose
looking like they're doing something
successful than win and be judged for
doing something that seems dorky i think
that there's a deep inherent
understanding in my in my mind that
there's only one at that and i don't
want to leave anything on the table most
people don't want to work
most people didn't find what they love
most people don't have enormous
ambitions most people prefer you to stop
because it makes them insecure while you
keep winning
there's no greater gift in life than to
have the people you love be happy and
healthy the second biggest gift in life
is to love what you do so much that you
only want to work what's your favorite
question to like
open up a conversation with i like for
me because it's my natural state because
i'm optimistic and positive i love to
compliment people if it's authentic
like if i genuinely think your purple
hair is rad then i'll be like your hair
is amazing
i would never do it if i knew who you
were
and i wanted to get to be your friend i
wouldn't say it i genuinely believe that
intent rules the world
that if you're doing it for the right
reason you win i'd rather say something
about your jacket or your sneakers or
or just say hello
but what my favorite thing is is if
there's something that i want to
compliment something on because it just
starts the vibe so nice i love being
self-aware i suck at a lot of things
i just don't think about them like i
can't read for
i interrupt people when i interview them
24 7. everybody's super pissed on the
internet about that not good because i
already know what the person's saying i
can't help it i'm sorry there's plenty
of things that i'm not good at i love
self-awareness i like it's kept me so
happy
like
you know i'm not upset of myself that
i'm selfish in certain areas
that's human i think that we just don't
love each other ourselves enough
i i think we
i don't know whose
perfection i'm trying to live up to
like if i like silly things like people
get on me for biting my nails
gives a f
like people are just critiquing
themselves all day long i'm 26
um i want to be
uh i i want to stay a marriage counselor
but every time i mention that like oh
you know what you want to do with your
life and i tell people this
um their instant response is
you know how you're going to do that
you're not married um
my parents are divorced as if i was
eight since i was eight um i'm not
married i can i can answer your question
right away we're gonna build an amazing
yeah we're gonna build an amazing case
study together i'm gonna give you i'm
gonna give you three names
um and then you're gonna cruise into the
sunset of success which is let's figure
out the three most successful coaches in
the history of sport that everybody
knows of that didn't play that sport
bill belichick even though i hate him
with all my guts did not play football
he grew up in the football game right
his dad and what was a coach or what
have you but bill belichick did not play
football and he will probably
unfortunately go down as the greatest or
if not one of the greatest head coaches
of all time you don't have to be listen
i think you have to be people have to be
thoughtful i hate 22 year old life
coaches that haven't lived life but if
they if they speak about here's my life
experiences and and why
you can eliminate though very quickly
the art when somebody says to you but
how are you gonna you can't do let me
first of all a couple other questions
are your friends and your circle telling
you you can't do that or are customers
that you're trying to do that with
telling you that they don't want to go
with you because you're not married
uh no this
this is more acquaintances uh people you
know that i run into yeah so
listen that's not the same listen that's
a
mistake
like you can't listen to acquaintances
their opinions don't matter
okay you can't listen
you you can't explain
that how do you walk out
i'm fine no go ahead i'm sorry i'm
getting excited you should talk go you
don't am i i'm like
um basically like i i wanna because i i
follow you and i've been following you
for a couple years now and i do agree
what you have to say about education i
do think people are gonna start
moving
from you know going to school and
sending their kids to school to finding
i've got your answer i've got your
answer and a lot of people get up you
know what i'm going to have of course i
know i know exactly where you're going
so if you're not going to get the phd
there's only a few ways to justify
and gives confidence to the end market
what what why they would jump with you
it's crazy to me that so many people i
was watching 60 minutes last night in
the background as i was working and the
way that oprah was justifying the person
was he has a phd in this and a master's
in that
even 60 minutes used those pieces of
paper to create a authority in our
society pieces of paper from businesses
and that's what colleges are has been
the authority the only other people that
get authority are the people that have
gone out and done it and have people
co-signing them right makes sense so the
way you're and this is why i love
working for free
when you don't have a piece of paper
right
one of the reasons i love working for
free is working for free for somebody
who is that person in society whether
they got a piece of paper or their puff
daddy and they just did it
becomes the equity that you trade under
once you become great at something right
andy andy who's sitting here right now
every single famous person i see gives
him a lot of street cred right away
not because he got a
degree for personal branding and
marketing for virginia tech what degree
did you get the science not because of
his [ __ ] political science degree
from virginia tech but because he went
and worked underneath me and i went out
and did it and i always give him love
and good vibes the end
it's not babin's degree from the usc
school of
film or nyu
i dropped out
you know so so what you need to do what
you need to do is one of two moves if
you're not gonna go get a phd and have
everybody comfortable with it you either
need to go work for somebody
that is the authority and ask all
thousands of people that are authorities
and work for them
or okay you need to give your services
for free to five couples crush it for
them and use their word of mouth and
endorsements and uh as your leverage
point the end technology and the way we
live doesn't care about my opinion or my
feelings and it doesn't care about yours
either and so you can walk around earth
and judge oh it's so sad that all these
kids can't communicate because they're
on the phone anymore and you could talk
about a day and age when it was simpler
and nicer and all this nobody gives a
and if you don't adjust to the reality
of the situation you will be completely
left behind too many people are
executing or hoping or trying to figure
out how to live in a world that used to
be or the way they wish it was versus
attacking the reality of the world
and here is the reality of the world my
friends
the cell phones that you're all holding
right now or in your pocket are the
remote controls of our society they are
the single most important thing in the
world there's nothing close whatever you
want to happen in life
you first need somebody's attention and
then you need to tell them about it it
was called the newspaper the television
and the radio now it's called a blog a
vlog or a podcast it's the same thing
nothing's changed except one thing
your attention is moving to a new place
and leaving an old place i'm making this
very simple
very black and white
very basic
if you do not spend next year
completely obsessing over how you become
successful on facebook and instagram
you will be disproportionately less
likely to win the ad product on those
two platforms are disproportionately
underpriced
and that that is where you should be
trading you are grossly underestimating
what's happening right now
98 of people are grossly underestimating
how good it is you will look back at
this talk all my content during this era
why am i producing so much content
during this era why am i flying around
the entire world over and over speaking
to this subject it's because i know what
i'm talking about right now
is gonna go away
and i think we can all agree i'm not
hedging up here right now
i'm desperately trying to force this
down your mouth
right
you heard it
and
i believe that 95 of you will not do
anything about it you'll do enough to
make it feel like you did something
[Music]
and you will regret not going all in how
many people here play poker
good
i don't but if you do
when you have the best hand
it's a good idea to go all in
one theme that i really people are like
yo how do i build my self-awareness how
do i build my optimism how do i change
my mindset it's the people around you if
your best friend is debbie downer you're
not gonna be as optimistic as you can be
if the people that from your town that
you hang out with have no ambition
you're going absolutely nowhere if you
listen to your dad every day about how
the government sucks you're not gonna
love life you've got to audit your inner
circle podcast friends listen to me
listen very carefully to this mashup and
these thoughts because this underlining
tone of who you surround yourself with
absolutely fundamentally changes who you
are period end of story when i hung out
with silicon valley in 2005 to 2010 i
was a different dude when i hang out in
the agency land right now i'm a
different dude when i'm like it's when i
was in college at mount ida different
dude like you're a different person and
i'm telling you right now
this morning podcast or this podcast
because i know some of you listen to it
at least this podcast if i can get one
of you one person listening to this to
dump one loser person in their circle
and add one whoever's that smiley
happiest person at work that you don't
talk to that much that's at the cubicle
around the way or that awesome like that
you know how everybody has like you have
a friend but their friend like went to
college with them you don't really know
them but like the three times you see
them a year they're positive
and like they're doing things surround
yourself with those people seek out your
friend's friend who brings positive
vibes and make them part of your world
and cut out your homie from college that
thinks the world sucks watch what that
addition and subtraction does to your
life how are you
what's your name alicia elise how you
doing i'm good good okay so
me my i want to become an author okay
just like you amazing and
i have been writing it's my passion
and i have i had applied to this
riding on yc teen and i spilled my heart
out it was just me it was just broad yes
they declined me yeah so it's like
it's like
they
yeah i get it it's like
that's me yeah it's like
they're not accepting me
them but it's like
should i
no but honestly guys first of all they
didn't decline you one random person
that read your declined you [ __ ]
but it's like imagine if i trained some
stuff up if i changed me they would have
probably took me you're wrong you're
wrong
listen to my face i'm telling you right
to your face you're wrong
you're valuing somebody else's opinion
too much
you're wrong
i i'm just telling i'm this is not this
is not a debate you're wrong
do you understand
you're letting one random person listen
you do you understand how many people
would have hired me
none
who's who's got instagram in here
cool go to it right now please do me a
huge favor go to instagram go to garyvee
that's my account go 1011 posts back
you'll see my report card i was ranked
243rd out of 254 in my class
[Music]
243 out of 254 in my class you know why
because i knew it was [ __ ] for me it
might not be [ __ ] for you this is
about self-awareness you have to know
who the [ __ ] you are
but for me it was [ __ ] because i
didn't need it
because i wasn't tr i didn't give a [ __ ]
saturn how many rings saturn had
listen to me
you can't let something be valuable more
than you you're pandering to them let
them come to you take that same essay
and post that on instagram with a photo
and see what happens
see what happens let the market decide
not some [ __ ] middle management
person that read your sh
good
of course it's true and when you're
young and 13 and 15 and 9 you think you
got to change your [ __ ] up because you
don't know how it's played that's why
i'm here to tell you exactly how it's
played
one person read your story my dear and
that person
for so many people that are complaining
that they don't have a big enough
audience how do you have the audacity to
wish for more fans when you don't go
into your own comments when you only get
17 of them and reply to the people that
are already part of your community
from 2007 to 2011 when nobody knew who
the guy was and twitter was the platform
of the day
i
spent every day
replying to every single tweet that made
a mention of me and used to go to sleep
at three and four o'clock in the morning
until i completely got to everybody
and that's how i built my foundation
people want the glitz and the glamour
and the caviar but they're not willing
to eat this
period
if if i mean if you don't understand how
this actually plays out there is no
shortcut
there's no hack there's no tip
there's just the work
every single thing i've ever done in my
life people thought was stupid until
they didn't
[Applause]
beautiful well because when you do
something early or that isn't mainstream
yet it's always going to be met with
cynicism
[Music]
the internet was a fad when i started
the whole thing
the whole internet
not flipping not
instagram the whole
framework
was going to be gone by the year 2000
all these people told me
y2k is going to kill the internet this
is some of the [ __ ] that i heard from
like people that
didn't know i was a super
entrepreneurial kid you know it's very
rare for somebody growing up in the 80s
uh who's an immigrant to not be blindly
bought into education is the way out
miraculously i have such a great mother
who saw
a four or five i mean young five six
seven eight year old kid basically spend
all his time on business
lemonade you know i was a four-season
executive you know in the fall i'm
raking leaves in the winter i'm
shoveling snow and singing christmas
carols at your door i mean i literally i
don't talk about that a lot i literally
rang people's doors and be like do you
want us well you pay us a dollar to sing
jingle bells me and my crew i mean it
was ludicrous and you're jewish right
and i'm jewish i mean it was like talk
about i'm entrepreneur first uh
you know in the spring it was like we
did a i remember we did a miniature golf
course we did flea mark mini flea
markets it was a garage sale in the
summer it was hardcore washing cars and
lemonade i was so passionate and then
very quickly for a lot of people
watching they'll probably remember this
in the late 80s early 90s the baseball
card phenomenon in america happened and
i was at the forefront not only was i
collecting but as a 12 year old i'm in
in hotels in malls in convention centers
set up as a dealer with other 30 40 50
year old men
uh and really cut my teeth there and
then my 14th birthday came and i for
whatever reason i guess that's grown up
in russia land my dad at this point in
parallel was also an entrepreneur more a
more significant one saved up all his
money as a stock boy and then manager of
a liquor store which is the job he got
in america and bought a liquor store and
dragged me into that liquor store in
springfield new jersey when i was 14 and
so from eighth grade on
i worked one of the things i saw a lot
in my comments because i read them all
was well i have no money i'm like
i lived my whole life with no money but
i figured it out i would just buy
i would buy garage sales and it just got
me going going i love it it's like a
hobby of mine to go garage sale start
doing that with clothes i did i used to
do that with clothes dude you met guys
especially like a stylish kid like you
like if you have flavor if you're
listening right now and you don't have
money but you're cool or you got flavor
you got swag you got style if you just
spend your life in goodwill
and in thrift stores yeah and buy that
you think is fresh
and then wear it and take a selfie and
put it on ebay for three times the price
or like i see every day the amount of
people that buy three dollar t-shirts
and sell them for 35 bucks on ebay and
etsy and facebook marketplace is
enormous there's no excuse in america to
say you have no money even if you're in
the deepest poorest places because if
you can literally get a dollar you can
buy your first t-shirt at goodwill and
get it up for 15 bucks on facebook
because you know what's funny
what's funny is everybody's got a
smartphone
like you go into the poorest places in
america and everybody's got a smartphone
which means you have the internet i mean
listen the homeless you've got people
all over on home homeless smartphones i
get emails every day i'm homeless i
watch you on youtube i've never done
anything financial a lot of good things
have happened to me that has remotely
hit my radar more than the year i made a
hundred thousand a year i would argue
that if you really knew everything about
me
and you read it all every action i ever
did you would look me in the face and
ask me
why do you sabotage yourself
in business and financial
environments and i would tell you that
deep down subconsciously i love it so
much that i just want it to happen
forever
and so for me
making it
is is a for you know it just there it
that's what that's what blows me away
about somebody who's like i just need to
make a million bucks and i'm gonna go to
jamaica right or or like i i don't have
that i don't have that in my head i just
want to play forever
um and that's why i'm trying to get
people to understand the process because
i it is very clear to me that people
that are in love with their craft and
process
can win and that's why i'm trying to
change the conversation around how much
money you need to be happy
because it doesn't work like i just know
unbelievable amounts of data of how many
people have lots of money how many
people don't have lots of money by our
standards and
how happy they are
and it doesn't take a lot of money to be
you know
to be alive in society it's about what
you spend it money on you like reading
the comments
love you do it on every video every post
all day how do you how do you deal with
the negativity someone's talking about
biting your nails empathetic
empathy
somebody just watched 49 seconds of me
spitting
some pontification on instagram
and they've decided to make a judgment
on me
and i respect that i put myself out
there
they don't know everything about me
so when they
drag me down be like this guy's a fan
who's full of or what the [ __ ]
i'm like that makes sense
they saw me in explore feature they're
like who's this face they watch it they
don't like it
and they decide i'm
and they're not in a good place so they
have to drag down
i deploy empathy first sucks to be i
would never do that as a happy person to
anybody else so hey i'm already feel bad
yeah and b who the [ __ ] am i they only
got 49 seconds and in 49 seconds at a
time i could suck
in perpetuity
like at 49 seconds at a time
i could be all-time terrible especially
me that gets hot and competitive and
like
you know like this is how i am when the
lights come on so
i deal with the negativity with empathy
to the person that's leaving the comment
a for the fact that i feel bad because
they're in a bad place that they decided
to put more hate into the system and b
like they shouldn't do seven hours of
research of my career or who i am as a
human being
i would be upset if you thought i was a
dick
because you've had enough interactions
at this point to have a read somebody
asked me today in an interview what do i
do with my down time
i told them that i
start other businesses
it's all i know it's who i am it's the
same way when i see a teacher or an
artist or anybody when i can see through
their soul that they were meant to cook
or paint or build or whatever it may be
i get such happiness it's the same
reason that people that i went to school
with who make fifty three thousand
dollars a year but i know they're so
happy because it's what they want they
want to be home at 5 p.m they want to be
on multiple sports teams they want every
weekend off they don't want the pressure
the greatest thing about being a ceo
founder entrepreneur is that when there
is success
you get a disproportionate amount of the
credit
the problem with entrepreneurship
is when it fails
you have nobody to blame
one of the things that i'm most worried
about is when you are a purebred
entrepreneur
you don't care about losing
the process is your religion
running the company is your oxygen
when you are not and you're doing it for
everybody else or because it's cool
when you fail
you will have no place to hide and your
loss will be very public and unavoidable
the reason i put so much pressure on
people being self-aware
is if you're a natural number 2
6 13 or 27
the negatives of being a number one are
overwhelming and very difficult to
quantify
you have to ask yourself today
that when your business fails
are you okay with the judgment of your
family friends your social media
followers and the entire world and if
you are then you can move on your merry
way but if you are not
one of the great ramifications of this
golden era of entrepreneurship is going
to be the enormous amount of depression
and mental illness when 99 of the
businesses fail
maybe you actually love playing video
games more than starting an app company
when i was growing up playing video
games was a waste of time today i think
we can all agree a professional esports
superstar for the next 50 years probably
behind proper football and basketball is
going to be the biggest athlete in our
world this is nothing you could see
seven or ten years ago
you must you must you owe it to yourself
to make sure that you're building a
company around what you love not because
cryptocurrency is the current fad
when you chase money you lose always and
forever even when you achieve the money
this is how humans are wired today i
lost 50 of all the money that i have
people are ditching me because they
don't want to go to the conference
anymore so i've been just full-on pissed
right getting on today yeah that sounds
awesome
yeah i like it
i like it
i like it i'll tell you why because i
even i can tell by your demeanor
that you're gonna be okay
the fact that you realize that that
negative moment has positive impact the
question is why did it happen and that's
why you have to be honest with yourself
i don't know
you know but that's you know i'm pumped
that you can have the i mean you're more
positive than half the people here and
it sounds like you're having a terrible
day
you know super rage that's why i wanted
to ask you how do you keep the
positivity in the calmness when
everything is
because basically when things happen i
go the other way
so tonight
i just was reminding myself every time i
every time you came and the next person
came i was just reminding my literally
in my own head saying you don't mean i
said to one of you
i said
they said how do you stay humble when
ever you're so successful i'm like
because i know if i die tomorrow i'll
have a good day on social media
like most comments ever on my latest
post on instagram and everybody's like
oh that was the last one weird and
and i know that all of you will be on
with your life a week later
you have to balance your ego with
humility in the same way when i'm having
my worst day i realize i'm the best
i'm gonna be the best that ever does
this and so
the way i handle things is when
something's going one way i use all my
emotional strength to push the other way
what are you gonna cry for the rest of
your life because the conference got up
like i just like to me it's just like
look what the [ __ ] guys
if you're in this room right now let me
just remind you that there are 7.7
billion people literally right now as we
stand here
there are women being shipped
to be strippers
in parts of our world right now as we
stand here there are women
who are basically caged
mentally usually and are being shipped
to dance on a pole in manhattan and in
london like do you understand what's
there's there's genocide going on right
now
like what do you think is going on
like we lack perspective your conference
got up boo hoo i lost a client boo hoo
there's people dying out there like like
so when americans or europeans talk to
me about race or gender
i'm sad it's their real life but i
remind them because it's a positive
thing
cool but
let me tell you about the person that's
ranked 7 billion in the world
they have it bad
and so i just i struggle like i want to
like i listen i'm weird i think about
things like animals like i don't know
like
if you're the best elephant we are still
better than you
like
you know like we got real like listen
you know i got hot on this about a year
ago the 400 trillion to one it's
impossible to be a human being you won
i don't know how to get upset after that
i keep [ __ ] in perspective right
like you're going to learn from this you
[ __ ] up
i promise you it's failing because of
you
and and when you start owning your
and not blaming other people and i think
this is the kick i've been on lately on
instagram right like blame yourself
uh you know why i'm always happy i blame
myself
when you blame yourself for real you're
gonna always be happy
because you don't feel like somebody
else controls you how do you balance
clouds in the dirt and what do you focus
on more and why so define to everybody
how i define clouds and dirt clouds to
me is like the why the strategy the
macro
the big thinking the big picture
the operating system of like how you do
things and then the dirt is having the
humility to go to these meetings to
actually i post all my instagram photos
the doing the
the humility ego humility
strategy execution clouds and dirt the
way i balance it is they're both
important at all times i can swing back
and forth to them i can literally go
from a meeting where
like the call i had on the way out to
our first meeting here today pirouette
was with vaynermedia's c-suite about a
restructuring of how we handle all our
business super meta and i literally hung
up and i posted something on instagram
and wrote all the copy as we were
walking into our last meeting to me i
balanced them by doing whichever one is
needed at the time
and so i don't think about it as
balancing it i think about it as time
allocation like what should i be doing
with my time
and i think that
you know you made a joke of like we did
a shoot for a client and we debated on
the phone for 10 minutes we're the
should be located
for that i think that's being in the
middle right i think uh
pandering to the way companies do things
we just had a meeting where they're like
oh that was provocative us as um as the
gallery media group holds
on all the other things we do us doing
what every other publishing does company
does is not a good idea that's the
middle that's not going to get you to
the next place and so for me
i'm just in the mindset of
you know
do either doing
humble dirty work like the reason i am
the best strategist in social media
out there i really believe this is
because i do both i both sit at the top
of a media
company that really does it at scale for
the biggest companies as well but at the
same token there's very few humans that
put out
140 pieces of content by hand a week and
reads the car i mean i literally just
replied to kyle in my comments who and
i'm going to show you because i don't
think you guys believe me when i do
these rants i literally just replied to
kyle one second before babin's like
let's do this video like literally what
i was doing one second before then
was
replying
to like literally like
literally hearted kyle's comment of i'm
digging the recent pics and quotes man
right like
many many people watching here would
argue that my time at this point in my
career of reading kyle's comment and
hearting it in that minute was a bad use
of my time i think the dirt
is the reason why i come up with such
good clouds being in the trenches drives
my strategy i live in reality and
practicality not in thesis or ideology
or reading headlines or reading about
people doing marketing uh so i don't i
don't balance it
i just do whatever
is needed at that second
mac you know it's back to macro micro
micro speed i'm just always doing
something
right bobby like that is the big
breakthrough everybody on the team says
like there's just every second is and so
the reason i can do something every
second is and i don't watch a youtube
video or stand by the wall water cooler
and talk about the rockets game for 10
minutes is because i always value the
dirt and so in that half a second that i
had right now in the transition of the
call that i just had about a macro
vayner x strategy
right
the second transition i had before i
started doing a macro thing like the
vlog
was harding kyle's two cents on my last
instagram post clouds and dirt if you're
trying to reach the decision maker at a
retail organization
that guy or gal
is also the same person that i want to
reach to sell a bottle of wine or a book
to and that space in his and her
facebook feed is only one space
so that is supply and demand i used to
buy that space four years ago for a
dollar for every thousand impressions
now it's seven the longer you think this
world doesn't exist and you fear monger
it the longer you don't put money in the
longer i can extract all the value i've
lived this game
i'm not a hero because i took it from 3
to 50 million 60 million my dad's
business
i actually am a schmuck i should have
spent more on google
i had it figured out
every time you typed in cabernet merlot
silver oak caymus napa bordeaux i was
showing up first because nobody realized
it was good real estate and it was only
costing me five or ten cents a click and
i was making between seven and eighty
dollars in profit for something that was
costing me three dollars to get you
through the funnel on the average of 60
people coming and one converting i was
stupid i'm being serious with you
i stand here and have passion about
linkedin and facebook marketing in a b2b
environment today out of regret for what
i did from 2002 to 2005 because i should
have spent more it was basic math but i
just didn't understand
because i was young in my career and it
just
i don't even know how to explain it to
you
when it's too good to be true it's too
good to be true right i'm an immigrant i
was cynical i just didn't plus i also
thought it was important to do direct
mail and local commercials and magazine
i was doing it all but in hindsight it
was the great mistake of my career the
great mistake of my career was not
spending more money on google and i
promise you the great mistake of your
accelerated growth for the 80 percent
that just raised your hand is not taking
advertising on linkedin and facebook
seriously because you don't think your
person is on it i've heard everyone guys
i've been doing this for 10 years i know
what your excuse is going to be i can't
wait to the q a i'm going to stand here
and want to but gary my my target person
is a 63 year old man he's not on it
[ __ ]
of course he's on it who do you think is
spreading all the democratic and
republican propaganda on facebook
my great legacy
in my aspiration to be someone that gets
written about like robin hood
is
giving it for free like the thing that i
if somebody asked me what are you most
proud of i'm literally giving away all
my best [ __ ]
for free
i don't know what else to say a lot of
people that kind of look like me
build audience to the masses but then
try to sell to that audience right right
here's the 4 000 ebook here's the come
to my mastermind what i do is back to
your analogy that's why i thought of it
too i do business with chase
and budweiser and triple a list
celebrities
but for the masses it's free i'm
obsessed with over delivering
it's why i say yes to like this in the
first place the fact that i get one of
the emails i get a day and i get a lot
of them that says i was at i was
suicidal like real [ __ ] that's heavy
that trumps anything i will ever do
professionally one one person telling
you that they were going to take their
life and that your videos and podcasts
made them not
is disproportionately greater
than if i bought all 32 nfl teams and i
mean that everybody gets hyped when i
hype them like this then they do it for
four days a week a month nothing happens
they're like that did you look carefully
at the 2009 and 2010 tweets how much
engagement they had
versus now yeah did you or not oh no you
know that some of those tweets only had
two likes and a share
i did not yes
people forget what my 2009 and 10 looked
like
everybody starts with only one like
here's the tactical part you put a ton
of content eventually something kind of
goes viral and you spend a lot of money
against it because people prove that
they gave
please understand
my biggest truth here today which is if
you are not sharing your thoughts
your process
your journey
your progress to achieving your goals
the stories you want to tell about your
startup product service if you are not
communicating to the world
and if you're not thinking about what's
valuable to them
not what's valuable to you when you
communicate and that is a very big point
i'll say one more time if you are not
communicating to the world
and when you're communicating if you're
not thinking about what's valuable to
them
versus what you're putting out for
yourself
you are basically irrelevant in a 2019
world
as much as it may be difficult for many
in this room
if you are not living through here
you are not known
this is the game if you are
underestimating this
and when i say underestimating this if
you have not made a significant
commitment to producing content for the
one of seven
apps or websites that eighty percent
of this entire region spends a
disproportionate amount of time
penetrating and listening and consuming
you're becoming vastly
vastly relevant people like gary i hit
up i dm'd all the influencers like you
told me nobody responded i'm like how
many they're like 130 i'm like good
there's about nine million more right
and you say will you help me no because
that's not the way to position it right
because most people want to answer that
because somebody who's got an audience
that's all they see right i would say
how can i help you right
that was my question you see where i'm
going yeah like
like yo i [ __ ] with you
like how can i help you
but then like if you don't have any
leverage yes you do you have your time
you never know drock didn't have any
leverage
drock asked me four times and then
finally i said yeah fine make me a video
not even that mindset and then this all
happened because of it that's real
that's real that's the story
that's the story he asked me four times
i want to make a video for you he was a
video guy i wasn't making content like
that then and but it was in my mind
and by the fourth time i was like you
know what okay okay
make me a free video show me
here we are
now he's the
the word that people use like people
literally say literally a verb
literally people are like that my
drock's name is rick i'm like you know
drock's a name
you know what i mean
it's real and and you know what i said
this at the time that director said
you're going to impact people like do
you know how awesome it is for people
that love to do it to do it you know
many people wanted to make documentaries
their whole lives yet only 74 people a
year get to do them and now 74 000
people you don't get to do it
all it takes is one person i just don't
care about the money yeah like i'm fine
making 47 000 a year and reading all the
comments on instagram and linkedin that
i was a loser and lost at all
interested
interested
so what do you want to be remembered for
the end that i gave a hell of a lot more
than i took
okay
i want to be i want to be the greatest
entrepreneur of all time
because entrepreneurship is what i do
and i think the way to do that is to a
build big businesses and exits and
companies and put the points on the
board right
but who i am
okay right yeah i mean like like i want
to inspire the most entrepreneurs to be
happy not just successful
okay like there's so many people who are
going to be unhappy making a million a
year that would have been thrilled
making 6 30. i'm secretly worried that
i'm going to get to a place where i'm
not going to care anything about
business and it's the love of my life
but i can like feel it already i'm like
you know 55 to 75 is gonna be some run
when you actually believe in the value
you're providing
selling
promoting
giving for free
when you believe
it all clicks
the reason people don't do
is because they don't believe they are
either are insecure and structured that
way or they deep down know they're doing
it for the money
how many people
like did things for me with expectation
a ton
and most of the times i'll say no
because i don't even want to do that but
once in a while i say yes
mainly to stick it to them
and teach them a life lesson
which is don't come at me and be like i
want to do this awesome thing for you
and then kind of hover around and always
have this weird relationship with me
where they expect something like we did
something here like if you told me up
front that the reason you bought 10 000
books
and did this thing was because what you
really wanted was my face on your
website co-signing your [ __ ]
business well then you should have told
me
because then we could have had a
transaction a lot of your advice is
geared to like college grads yep but i'm
old i'm 40. what would you like what
would your voice advice be for someone
who's 40 but starting out where most of
your audience is starting out when
they're 20 or 30. well it's interesting
no joke i don't know if you saw this i
literally posted a video today to 47
year olds
i did not see that yet so
uh to me everybody's going through
different things you know i to your
point last 8 12 to 18 months i found
myself producing a lot more content to
youth than i have in the past which was
usually to more 40 year old business
people
um
look i think the biggest thing with 40
to 50 is that it's now you've lived life
and you're still young as
and you're like now what right you have
like an entire second life to live
and it's a very interesting time in
people's lives where they have to be
really retrospective of like how
self-aware are they
but honestly i think 40's young man i
really really do and so i would say a
lot of the advice i give to 20 year olds
maps pretty well to 40 year olds which
is
you know take some risks you've tasted
some stuff
you know
happiness is the roi and so you know
figure out what makes you happy is it
the pursuit of money or is it actual
money do materials make you happy if
materials make you happy is that really
just insecurity and you need to have you
know a bmw to make yourself feel good
like what's making you tick but i would
say the biggest thing that i would tell
any 40 year old is you've got 50 years
to live please get the um finished or i
[ __ ] up
like eliminate dwelling because you're
just starting i really believe that by
the way this is not some motivational
raw rush
i just think it's true i just think
you've got 40
adult years to live that's 20 more than
you've lived and there's just so much
opportunity the reason we're sitting
here today is i decided from 2007 to
2011 to spend four to eight hours a day
replying to people on twitter
that weren't even talking to me you
could type in the hash the name of that
town and then go in instagram and then
go to places click it and see every
photo that's been posted
in your town
in that town
you can then go look at the photo it
could be her at a goodwill saying huge
score
you could reply and say good
seven to 150 on a stapler go girl
now all of a sudden she's just a normal
human she only gets six comments to
begin with she's like who's this man she
clicks she goes your bio is i sell homes
she's like cool nice guy i hope he's not
weird and she's out right but the 97th
person that does that goes he seems nice
goes in the funnel you put out a good
piece of content like
i'm gonna dm him i'm thinking about
selling my home
what people don't understand is how much
work i put to even begin the process of
being who i am today
2007 2011's a long time ago for a lot of
people
that year i decided to go on twitter
search and anybody that talked about
wine i jumped in and talked to them
how did i get here
hand to hand combat to build a
meaningful company takes a very long
time
is very difficult and more importantly
what has happened in the startup
community all those wonderful startups
back there
everybody now is pandering to venture
capital or to raising capital not to
actually building a business
every day
thank you
it's important
and and thank you so much for jumping on
that it's important because let me let
me tell you why
in 2006 789 i was taking all of my money
and investing in tumblr and facebook and
twitter and uber and all these things
that i did very well with
and why over the last four years i've
invested very little
very carefully
because there's a disconnect right now
and there's illusions of the reality if
you stand here or sit here today and
there is nothing that you could think
about other than building a business
because the process of building a
business is your happiness
not what a successful business allows
you to buy well then you're a purebred
entrepreneur there is nothing
nothing more difficult than navigating
your life based on somebody else's
opinion
you actually care about what your dad or
mom or grandma or husband or wife or
daughter or son is gonna say about you
if you do this thing it doesn't matter
what they think when you're 92 and
you're sitting there you're not gonna
give a [ __ ] about what punkman96
had to say or even what your aunt had to
say who's miserable because she never
got hers so she's trying to keep you
down negative people latch on to
positive people and try to seclude them
from the world because that's their
energy
in work i see it every day in life i see
it every day it's just what it is
i hate
how many people judge other people
without having all the context every
time you judge you make yourself
vulnerable 99.9 of people that you judge
or have opinions on you have no idea
what is actually happening in their
lives like you don't know what's going
on in somebody's home
everybody sucks at something right like
we all have shortcomings and for me it's
like why don't we just audit that like
why don't we just look at it that way
and be like all right well i'm good at
this but i'm not good at that like
everybody's so absolute
[Music]
are you really really really not going
to live your life based on somebody's
anonymous
icon feedback that you suck they suck go
do your thing don't listen to anybody
but what's in your mind and your heart
and not living a life where you allow
other people's judgment to dictate your
behavior
if you can have perspective proper
macro perspective and you can have micro
you know practitionership
you will be happy and win yeah i really
believe that yeah
having the humility
and the audacity
back to your contradiction
but yeah i mean that's how i got to
clouds and dirt you know yeah
because i've always been fascinated by
that about me which is
um
the things i'm willing to do
right now that are below my paid grade
this
podcast this is super scrutinized by the
people around me right they're like why
are you doing this we don't have 15
minutes for very important
you're letting money opportunity vips
why are you doing this i don't know like
intuitively when we were talking i
thought it was a good idea and i want to
i think you know in my massive pers you
know perspective giving back i look
you're going to leverage
me being on this show absolutely for
sure and that makes me feel good that's
me giving back right this is a bigger
thing giving you these 15 minutes than
me giving you 15 000 for your app for
sure for me it's easier to write the
chat
so so for me um
humility and like perspective like i
don't think i don't know how many very
busy people are running around
knowing that they need to put change
into the bucket of giving back
in their time not their money you could
be everything like be like be the
greatest actor actress
singer be an accountant be be everything
you can be like you got one life don't
let people put you in a box everybody's
trying to put people in a box
if you're talented enough do everything
if you're bo jackson and deon sanders
play both
for example i'm a good operator and i'm
a good personality so i do both some
people are good personalities but can't
run a business some can run a business a
kid some people can cook and sing some
people can't like do you like if you can
do comedy and
music then go if you're good enough
you'll always get it
the rock was a wrestler now he's a movie
star will smith was a
rapper then he was a movie star marky
mark was a rapper that he was a movie
star like if you're ashton kutcher was
an actor now he's a footballer
businessman if you're good enough
nobody's gonna stop you evan thank you
so much for having a couple seconds and
being able to tell the believe nation a
little bit about empathy wines it means
a lot to me that you would take this
valuable real estate and and time on
your channel to give me some love means
a lot it's just good karma points and so
you're just you're awesome thank you
believe nation uh if you're into wine at
all go to empathywines.com
my whole career's work was poured into
producing a wine that rivaled 40 to 60
wine for 20 bucks a bottle uh i'm just
super excited about this
subscription-based wine business you can
order three six or 12 bottles in
subscription forum rose white red
if you if you search on instagram or or
twitter you will be blown away people
are literally like i don't even like
garyvee but the wine's good super proud
of the effort thanks evan for the time
uh wishing you guys all happy and
healthy because you made it this far in
a video i want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe nation you made it here
all the way to the end and i love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
below on this video i will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome to see my recent one-on-one
interview with gary on how to turn
kindness into your superpower check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there i'm talking about
something that the world thinks is a
contradiction i don't understand why
anybody
should ever verbally dress down
an employee